well we finally have a trailer for class
actually those little characters spot
teaser trailers they've come out with
this week this probably would have been
fine enough as a teaser trailer for
glass just have Elijah prices mom's
audio from unbreakable while they're
showing that this the soldier fights the
fever with his hands and then there's
the brilliant evil
it's not I'd have been fine if that was
a teaser trailer but we got a lot more
so in a world where we have a teaser
trailer to glass the sequel to
unbreakable the third chapter in the
unbreakable split saga who I'm talking
about that I tried to keep it from you
all until now but I can no longer do it
split is tied to unbreakable and that
was revealed at the end of split it was
just it was a swell of cheers in the
audience myself included this trailer
essentially starts out with Sarah
Paulson she's talking to someone she's
talking to David Dunn Kevin and Elijah
price mr. glass they're all in a room
together but Sarah Paulson says she
specializes with people with a certain
type of delusion of grandeur which is
people who think they're superheroes and
this is a growing field it's a growing
thing it's a growing epidemic she does
make sense because the superhero movie
genre has grown in our world that's what
unbreakable was unbreakable was a
looking glass mirror into the superhero
genre and it was an interesting
realistic reflection into that world /
what it was in 2000 but now is 18 years
later and the superhero movie genre is
completely changed now everything's
crossover cinematic universes is bigger
so now it looks like there might be
other people in this movie who have
abilities also abilities which are the
truth the comic books being the
exaggeration of that truth I just hope
the theme doesn't get lost in that
Elijah price and unbreakable even says
their exaggerations of the truth comic
books are a form of history that someone
wrote down then that history got chewed
up in the commercial machine and now we
have what we have we have comic books
and I just hope I hope I'm breakable the
unbreakable universe I guess is the word
I hope it doesn't get chewed up in the
commercial machine we get something that
doesn't really resemble unbreakable and
I'm just addressing concerns I do think
it's completely possible to do it right
I think you can have more people that
might have powers in this world without
losing the purity of what unbreakable is
just an experience in history for
learning from history because those who
don't learn from history are doomed to
repeat it history has been the bigger
shot Milan goes the less good the movie
is so he doesn't try to go to big
special props without one scene where
mr. glass sees that comic strip and it's
someone bending the bars which is
exactly what the Beast did and split
that's what it is this this movie looks
like it's going to be but Elijah prices
mom was talking about it was the soldier
villain who fights the hero with his
hands and there's the more dangerous
arch enemy who fights the hero with his
mind so now you have the soldier villain
and the arch enemy you know David Dunn
which is have to if he ever finds mr.
glass you just walk up to him and go pow
dead
why he's even in a room with him he
David Duns in a room with a couple of
murdering maniacs I feel like I could
just break out of the chains be like
you're knocked out you're you might be
dead maybe David Dunn has a problem with
killing people that's fine let me just
snap your arms so you can't wheel
yourself around and cause trouble I do
it I don't know why I expect this but I
expect Sarah Paulsen's going to be one
of them one of the special people I
don't know we'll see what happens but
the fact that she's in it - something
about her it just it's it screams
inquisitive person who's trying to
accept who she is I imagine that would
be a really interesting thing for M
night Shyamalan to do one of the fun
parts of writing this is finding
superhero powers and then finding a way
to just tone it back and make it a
realistic thing it looks to be the case
from the trailer and I'd love for this
to be the case
David Don's in a place he's not supposed
to escape from dem mr. glass puts people
in danger which case he does have to
bust out of there and save them but he
has the Beast like a dog on a leash he
unleashes him to fight dunge that's
really the only way he could ever fight
David done even have Kevin the Beast
fighting done and kryptonite and by
kryptonite I mean water that is his
kryptonite he'll be happen chance could
be planned by glass but mr. glass doing
this again with him it was inevitable at
the point David done picked up the
mantle and became the hero and became
who he was supposed to be thus showing
Elijah price who he is supposed to be
it's just showing you here supposed to
be but what's the point of that if you
don't keep on the path if you don't keep
on being mr. glass through action it's a
true Batman and Joker dynamic right
there actually for most of this video
I'm just kind of hypothesizing and
theorizing which is part of what makes
us so interesting for me it's been 18
years if it had only been a couple years
or a few years like unbreakable 2 was
coming out like 2002 or 2005 the time
gap in between the movies is shorter so
there are less variables there are less
possibilities of what the characters
have been doing since 18 years that's a
long time you could really go anywhere
far too long but I hope it's the case of
the longer the wait the better the
reward I think we can have ourselves a
winning trilogy on our hands right so
the trailer for glass have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]